yes
yes Loki season two I've seen the first
four episodes and for those who know me
for those who follow the channel you
probably have heard me say Loki season
one is my favorite MCU show and with
season two that remains true I was so
excited for this and it didn't
disappoint which is like
it's so good to feel that way because I
was so excited but worried that it
wasn't gonna do season one justice but
right away episode one is just
It's amazing And it picks up you know
right where we left off with the last
episode of Loki season one it goes right
into it and it's chaos and it's epic now
this isn't a review I am going to be
doing a spoiler-free review for Loki
season two tomorrow at 7 00 a.m so be on
the lookout for that this is just my
first initial reactions and honestly
they're pretty dang good it's very
comparable to the first season there's a
lot of mystery to it the tone is
something that I've just always really
loved about the Loki series and it's
there the characters are there the same
ones that we know they're great there's
some new characters that are also great
Gotta Give It Up to Kiwi Kwon like his
character Obi he is so good at it he's
his character's so good he's quirky and
it's amazing
I think fans are going to be really
excited with this I think this is going
to restore some faith and some of those
fans who are kind of you know barely
holding on to the MCU I've seen the
comments I've seen your complaints and I
understand but this to me
is a game changer now one thing I will
say and I'll leave it at this is that
again I've only seen the first four
episodes and
it did kind of end
with a big question mark I'm really
curious to see what happens in episode
five and six and I will say depending on
what happens
that'll determine if the show is going
to be truly amazing for a second season
or just kind of like pretty good
because it's it's fantastic so far there
are some slow parts to some episodes but
overall again the tone and the the
mystery and everything to it it fits
really really well and there's a lot of
fast-paced parts as well a lot of like
shocking moments but depending on what
they do
with the next part it'll really it's not
gonna be make or break because it's
again it's really good but
they could make it just truly fantastic
if they end it right and I feel like
it's going to really dive into the next
part of the MCU as well so we'll see how
it connects we'll see how it ends I I'm
actually kind of
curious I mean I don't know how it's
gonna end which is crazy because
typically I have a decent idea based off
things I've heard or theories in my mind
but now I'm like there's a lot of ways I
could go with it there's a lot of things
I could do it could be fantastic and I
think it is going to be fantastic
because seriously they they nailed it
with season two it feels just like
season one just like a continuation so I
I'm super super excited again I'll say a
lot more in my spoiler free review
tomorrow we might dive into a little bit
of spoilers at the end but I'll you know
do a spoiler warning before so if you're
curious about that tune in tomorrow and
uh yeah let me know how excited you are
for Loki season two I'll see you in the
video tomorrow